Hollywood Blockbusters have become
increasingly reliant on visual effects
over the past few decades in recent
advances in technology have made it so
Feats and VFX work that were considered
impossible just a few years ago are now
well within reach more and more studios
are using CGI and films mostly because
it's often cheaper than the alternative
in fact many modern Blockbusters are
covered in so many digital layers that
the original footage looks
unrecognizable and more often than not
completely ridiculous here's what these
movies really look like before special
effects were added 300 Rise of an Empire
Zack Snyder's 300 made heavy use of CGI
and the technology used to create it had
Advanced immensely by the time its
sequel Rise of an Empire came around
which of course meant squeezing every
ounce of that Tech into the movie
director no Muro told Forbes it's
amazing how the tools available eight
years later continue to develop a major
difference is CGI and the ability to
create things in posts that are
convincing and complex and
three-dimensional the idea of creating a
water movie without a drop of water on
the set is remarkable the filmmaker also
revealed that they relied on some of the
same techniques used in the
oscar-winning CGI Blockbuster gravity
Elysium
Neil blomkamp's follow-up to his
acclaimed debut District 9 didn't
exactly go as planned despite the star
power of Matt Damon the Blockbuster
sci-fi film cost a whopping 115 million
dollars to make but only returned 93
million dollars at the domestic box
office but while blomkamp took full
responsibility for the film's failings
the South African director didn't have
any complaints about the special effects
team which had to put together over
three times as many VFX shots as they
had for district 9.
Jurassic World
when Steven Spielberg decided to adapt
Michael crichton's novel Jurassic Park
CGI as we know it today didn't really
exist Spielberg brought on industrial
Light and magic and tasked them with
creating living breathing dinosaurs
using computer-generated graphics and
their efforts proved revolutionary of
course it wasn't just CGI that brought
the inhabitants of Jurassic Park to life
there were a number of practical effects
used too and ilm mixed it up in the same
way for Jurassic world the fourth film
in the franchise used detailed white
casts of dinosaur heads that would later
be layered with CGI for close-up shots
and the used actors in motion capture
suits to make sure their movement seemed
real VFX supervisor Tim Alexander told
below the line it gave us a new natural
look for the animation we ended up
casting a person to give us a
consistency in the performance there
were individual people being that Raptor
we had suits that they would put on with
a tail
Mad Max Fury Road when George Miller
returned to the world of Mad Max with
his critically acclaimed Fury Road in
2015. audiences were blown away by the
sequel's frenetic pace and visceral
action much of which was achieved
through the hard work of inventive
mechanics who built the vehicles used in
the movie from scratch the chase scenes
were all shot for real but the final
product wouldn't have looked anywhere
near as eye-popping if it weren't for
the VFX team led by supervisor Andrew
Jackson hundreds of CGI artists enhanced
over 2 000 shots in Fury Road from
adding characters to creating an epic
toxic storm
The Avengers
when Earth's Mightiest Heroes teamed up
on the big screen in 2012 the stakes
were high for Marvel Studios and their
team of visual effects artists Jeff
White the film's VFX supervisor told MTV
with Adventures there were so many
things to get right we created a lot of
New York City for the film and needed to
build flying shots of Iron Man all from
photography we had to build a new Iron
Man suit the Mark VII and Stark Tower we
had to build the alien race when you add
all of those things up there were quite
a few challenges there green screens
were used during most of the film's
action sequences so the cast's been a
good chunk of time reacting to Invisible
threats and taking cover from fake
explosions the biggest hurdle they faced
was inserting the Hulk into group
situations white explained we wanted it
to feel very natural when he's sitting
in that Circle of Avengers we spent a
lot of time working on his skin and his
hair and his teeth just to make sure all
of that was believable
Man of Steel
to create the illusion of flight Richard
Donner's Superman employed wire rigs to
hang leading man Christopher Reeve in
front of different projected backgrounds
the film is a classic and the effects
look great in the 70s but watching it
today it feels as though you're flying
with Superman as opposed to him flying
past you something Man of Steel director
Zack Snyder wanted to avoid when he set
out to make Superman soar Snyder decided
to use a handheld approach to filming
Clark's flying scenes which meant adding
in most of the effects in post wire Rigs
and gimbals were used to suspend Henry
Cavill in front of green screens and the
CGI team did the rest
Iron Man 3. when the first Iron Man
movie dropped in 2008 director John
Favreau wasn't known for CGI heavy
features but advances in technology had
convinced him to change his stance I've
always steered away from using visual
effects whenever possible that being
said in the last few years there have
been a lot of wonderful visual effects
movies where I it it's beginning to
become seamless even to me fafro
returned for the sequel but Shane black
took the reins for Iron Man 3 which
contained some of the most challenging
visual effects yet Marvel Studios head
honcho Kevin feige explained we wanted
the ability to be able to suit up
anywhere anyhow without a giant Gantry
the answer was having Tony Stark design
Outlets he injects just below the skin
not unlike the comics allowing him to
call the Iron Man suit from anywhere to
pull off the effect each individual
piece had to be digitally added to
Robert Downey Jr's body after the fact
Spider-Man homecoming years of
gymnastics training really paid off for
Tom Holland on the set of Spider-Man
homecoming the characters eagerly
anticipated introduction to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe even with the
advances in CGI in recent years it helps
to have an actor who feels comfortable
jumping around in tights and doesn't
mind hanging around on wires all day
long this was the case with the film's
Washington Monument scene but while that
was indeed Holland under the Spidey mask
the monument itself was a fake erected
on the studio Sound Stage we couldn't
film it the real washing Monument but we
built very impressive very large chunks
of the monument for filming Holland got
up the structure with the aid of a wire
rig though even with his background it
was far from a walk in the park we did
two weeks and every single shot was
upside down and my head just took a
pounding man from all the Bloods that
was rushing to it The Jungle Book the
CGI John Favreau used for Iron Man was
nothing compared to what he did for his
2016 live action adaptation of the
Jungle Book to create an entire jungle
around a human actor they needed to pull
out all the stops the lighting was
particularly difficult the director
explained it's very hard to fake light
and Shadow so everything became about
using panels of LEDs to project light so
if we had the kid bowing before the
elephants you have panels where we
actually would pre-animate the elephants
and they would cast the Shadows on the
kid in the exact right way this meant
the 12 year old star Neil seti had to
imagine the animals he was interacting
with though Favre was on hand to make
the experience as real as possible for
the young actor via puppets and actors
in blue suits
RoboCop Paul verhoven's RoboCop got the
most out of the special effects
available in the 80s using a combination
of stop-motion and prosthetic builds to
create a movie that was disturbingly
realistic at times in a 2014 reboot
Murphy gets his injuries in an explosion
that was created digitally but the suit
he thoughts afterward was actually real
and there was a philosophy from the
start that we're gonna have a head to
toe suit the challenge was building a
suit that was mobile and easy for the
digital Department to add on to
the Martian Ridley Scott is no stranger
to special effects but creating the red
planet on screen for the Martian may
have been his biggest challenge as a
director while some practical effects
were used a huge amount of digital work
was required to give the Martian Scott's
desired look VFX supervisor Anders
lenglands told Gizmodo Ridley Scott is
famous for doing his little sketches
which are sort of really cool Ridley
grams we'd ask what do you want the
background mountains to look like in
this shot and he'd sketch out a little
diagram of what they wanted so you just
literally matched that and he'd be happy
a lot of time was spent finding the
right Hue for the skies and arid
Landscapes of Mars though in the end it
was a simple thing that caused the VFX
team the most problems the helmet visors
but of course glass visors would reflect
the crew and the lights and the Sound
Stage so all the helmet visors you see
in the film are actually added in
digitally
Suicide Squad David Ayers anti-hero
Ensemble Suicide Squad definitely had
its flaws but few of those were the
fault of the many visual effects houses
18 companies in total that worked
tirelessly on it image Works were the
ones who handled the squad's final
battle with enchantress and the movie's
villain proved to be a huge challenge
according to VFX supervisor Mark
breakspeare he told Art of VFX
enchantress was a unique challenge as
the actress had been shot without a
costume as we had to add it in later to
allow it to behave in a way that normal
cloth or materials couldn't break spear
later told awn that of the 300 shots
they enhanced for the film's third act
dealing with the enchantress's tattoos
proved the most difficult that was
amazingly tricky to make sure it looked
like skin but also had the translucency
that we needed to see the subsurface
tattoos
The Wolf of Wall Street Watching Martin
scorsese's Ode to excess The Wolf of
Wall Street the only scenes that stick
out as being possibly computer generated
are the one during which Jordan
Belford's yacht sinks and the one when a
lion wanders freely through his office
but a visual effects reel released by
brainstorm digital revealed that some of
the most basic shots in the movie were
rendered with CGI from Sun loungers to
tennis courts brainstorm made plenty of
subtle touches to bring the film in line
with the director's Vision VFX producer
Mark Russell told Digital Arts working
with Martin Scorsese everything is about
propelling a story forward and
contributing to the film I feel that
with his movies there is a kind of
stylized realism to them that we have to
integrate with
San Andreas the amount of Destruction on
show in this Dwayne johnson-led
Blockbuster definitely doesn't come
cheap but San Andreas actually cost a
lot less to make than many of the big
natural disaster flicks that came before
it according to variety the production
budget was only 114 million dollars
roughly half the amount needed to bring
Roland emerick's 2012 to the big screen
the film's visual effects supervisor
Colin Strauss was able to keep costs
down by employing practical solutions to
problems that most visual effects
companies would solve with only
computers today as he explained it you
can make a 100 million dollar movie look
like a 200 million dollar movie you can
make movies way smarter CG for the sake
of CG is always a mistake they still
have their work cut out for them though
seven different companies work together
to render 1300 VFX shots for the movie
as movies become more and more reliant
on computer effects the entire landscape
of filmmaking is changing and sometimes
there aren't any Landscapes at all
because it's all done in front of a
green screen
the end result movie sets look
completely ridiculous here's a behind
the scenes look at what some of your
favorite movies looked like before the
special effects team went to work the
Planet of the Apes effect Studio WETA
digital changed the game when they
helped reboot Planet of the Apes with a
new Trilogy of prequels beginning with
2011's Rise of the Planet of the Apes
producer Dylan Clark had a special
amount of praise for Andy Circus the
industry's top performance capture
artist shown as protagonist Caesar
redefining screen acting in the digital
age
Andy Circus is unlike any other actor he
can inhabit characters that don't speak
and emote in ways that you don't really
see often Fox campaigned for circus to
get an Oscar nomination but the call
from the academy never came much to the
actor's frustration after the release of
2017's War of the Planet of the Apes
circus told independent the awarding
bodies should not discriminate about
this being different the visual effects
render the character just like putting
on makeup except here it happens after
the fact it's digital makeup if you will
Harry Potter bringing JK Rowling's
Wizarding World to life was only ever
going to be possible with the help of
CGI and the films made increasingly good
use of visual effects with each
installment while early CGI hasn't aged
well the quality of digital imagery from
Goblet of Fire onward still holds up the
VFX team had to up their game for the
fourth film in the series as it marked
the return of Lord Voldemort Paul
Franklin the VFX supervisor for Order of
the Phoenix and Half-Blood Prince
revealed that creating Voldemort's nose
was a mammoth task Franklin told radio
times there's this idea that we put the
shots through the computer and it just
vanished off his face his nose had to be
painstakingly edited out frame by frame
over the whole film and then the snake
slits had to be added and tracked very
carefully using dots put on his face for
reference that's a lot of work for a
couple no slits but Voldemort just
wouldn't have been the same without them
nothing's too good for James Potter
Life of Pi filming this tale of a boy
stranded at its sea with a Bengal tiger
came with a number of obstacles but the
biggest one wasn't the tiger it was the
water director Ang Lee explained I knew
that to make it work with 3D water had
to become a character itself I've never
seen realistic water scenes in movies
because water hits one side of a tank
wall and bounces back like it would in a
bathtub but we needed to make it work
that's not to say the tiger was easy to
create either scenes in which Pi
interacts with the deadly animal were
done using a crude puppet the rest of it
had to come from CGI Game of Thrones the
season finales on Game of Thrones always
have a cinematic quality thanks in part
to the digital Wizardry of pixel Mondo
green screen use is kept to a minimum
where possible but bringing the
creatures of George R.R Martin's world
into the mix requires some top-notch CGI
pixel Mondo's VFX supervisor Sven Martin
told the Washington Post that one of
their biggest achievements has been
making Daenerys dragons blend seamlessly
with the world around them but all that
magic doesn't happen until the dragon
scenes have been shot so how does Emilia
Clarke connect with her fire-breathing
babies green puppets the actress told
Huffington Post they have these Amazing
Life scale models that we use for camera
rehearsals for the sake of the CGI
people and I got very attached to them
fundamentally they're dolls I suppose
but it was nice to have something
physical that I could really picture in
my mind Alice in Wonderland Tim Burton
was creating stunning visual effects
long before relying heavily on CGI using
a combination of practical techniques to
bring his vision to the screen the
former Disney artist used stop-motion
animation Miniatures and puppetry to
great effect in his earlier works though
in the opportunity to direct his own
version of Alice in Wonderland came
along he soon realized that he couldn't
do it without leaning heavily on digital
Wizardry this means that all the stars
of the movie had to do the bulk of their
acting in front of green screens
according to visual effects supervisor
Ken Ralston it was a challenge for the
whole team the green screen color after
long periods of time seems to create a
certain aggravation and irritation after
staring at it for long period it is
effective for compositing but visually
and psychologically exhausting to be
surrounded by it for extended periods of
time Beauty and the Beast when Disney
first announced their intention to
remake a number of their beloved
animated Classics and live action format
the title that raised the most eyebrows
was Beauty and the Beast a film in which
the majority of the supporting
characters are animated household
objects was always going to rely on CGI
though director Bill Condon has never
liked digital effects and actively
avoided using them wherever possible he
told indiewire it was important to make
everything that could be real real I'm
not a big fan of CG movies the idea is
to feel grounded in a world and not be
distracted by things that felt like
additions unfortunately for the actor
portraying the Beast Dan Stevens it was
motion capture all the way plus some
stilts to get him to the right height it
wasn't easy on stilts Steven spoke to
both Andy Circus and Mark Ruffalo about
their experiences in motion capture
roles and their feedback left him
sweating he added I think I was mildly
terrified but that's really generally
what drives a lot of my decisions these
days is calibrating the right amount of
Terror nothing like a Disney movie to
get that fear meter up right The Dark
Knight Christopher Nolan is notorious
for using real life effects as much as
possible and most of the big effects in
the Dark Knight were done on camera the
only visual effect involved in that
scene was to remove the ram that they
had built inside the truck but the Dark
Knight still offered some unique CG
challenges especially since it was the
first film to shoot scenes with IMAX
cameras as opposed to using 35
millimeter and converting in post visual
effects supervisor Nick Davis spoke to
Studio daily about his experience on the
Batman flick saying it was important for
the visual effects to look as though
they were shot on set Nolan didn't want
the film to take on a gimmicky visual
effects look taking this route meant
that Nolan's first sequel to 2005's
Batman Begins was a difficult movie to
finish as the visual effects had to be
rendered in a higher resolution than
ever before when it came to creating the
look for Harvey two-faced Dent Nolan
wanted to remove layers not add them the
VFX team had to digitally remove the
skin two faces exposed eyeball had to be
painstakingly animated by hand as where
the subtle changes in muscle tension
Gravity the biggest challenge Alfonso
coron faced making his space epic
gravity was achieving a realistic lack
of gravity on screen pulling it off
involved an intricate mixture of
practical and digital effects now there
are flares and there are mistakes as it
were but no mistakes it's all created
the director talked to space about the
challenges in getting the effects to
look realistic saying it took a lot of
education for the animators to fully
grasp that the usual laws of cause and
effect don't apply in outer space there
is no up there is no down co-stars
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney were
advised of their movements by real
astronauts before being hooked up to a
series of rigs created by Academy
award-winning visual effects artist Neil
corbold it turns out that Bullock not
only had to put up with being suspended
from wires most of the day there were
electric shocks to contend with too
corbold explained there was a charge in
there like the static you feel
underneath an electricity substation if
you walked out then touched someone
you'd get this massive shock it may not
have been easy work for the actors but
it worked out pretty well for corbold
who won his second Oscar for gravity The
Matrix arguably one of the most
influential films of all time the Matrix
truly changed the landscape of action
movies with its memorable fight
sequences becoming a benchmark for stunt
coordinators and VFX artists alike the
term bullet time was coined for the Epic
slow motion shots that the movie
employed on the regular which were
created by visual effects Guru John Gada
Gada told the New York Times the
directors wanted to emulate the
stylization found in Japanese animation
when we created weather fire and smoke
we wanted it to move not realistically
but impressionistically raw footage
released as an extra on the DVD showed
how bullet time was achieved using an
intricate setup of perfectly positioned
cameras and masses of green screen
the Lord of the Rings whenever Peter
Jackson's The Lord of the Rings trilogy
comes up the first thing most people
mention is Andy circus's brilliant
motion capture performance though
creating Gollum was just one of many
challenges what a face during the movies
practical Solutions like miniature
models and forced perspective were used
in places but the bulk of the visual
effects were achieved digitally even the
interior of Bilbo baggins's Hobbit Hole
was computer generated for some shots
speaking to awn visual effects
supervisor Jim Riegel revealed that
Return of the King was his favorite of
the three movies because of the
Monumental amount of work he and his
team put into the picture he explained
Return of the King has more shots than
one and two combined it's like 1 450. it
was mind-boggling to figure out
logistically how to do them all it's
something you never think you could have
done and you did it like climbing Mount
Everest Pirates of the Caribbean Dead
Man's Chest Bill nye's character Davey
Jones made his first appearance in 2006
as Dead Man's Chest although you may not
have recognized the actor under all
those digital 10 tentacles I was once
required to be a squid man in a movie I
was an octopus guy and I was perfectly
happy watching that because what are you
going to say my you don't like my squid
well then you know live with it visual
effects supervisor John Knoll was able
to develop a method that allowed naive
to be on set with his fellow actors
instead of filming separately in front
of a green screen which in turn allowed
him to interact more believably and
deliver a far more genuine performance
Knoll described the process to ew saying
on a sound stage with 25 technicians
staring at Bill and nobody to play off
of that quirkiness would have all gotten
ironed out somebody would say that
gesture is too off or too odd it could
have become a real sort of committee
effort my squid was World close my my
squid was an award-winning squid because
the hundred men and women who created my
squid the post-credits scene in Pirates
of the Caribbean Dead Men tell no Tales
opened the door for the return of
Supernatural Sea Lord Davy Jones
although naive had no part in it in fact
he had no idea his award-winning squid
was even in the movie until a taxi
driver told him about it
it might be the A-list Stars donning The
Capes and masks but the real heroes of
today's CGI heavy comic book movies are
the special effects artists the men and
women who really make it all possible of
course if you're not convinced that's
the case just try watching those movies
before the effects were added in
2014 was a big year for Marvel movies
beyond the obvious successes of the MCU
FOX also released its eagerly awaited
X-Men sequel Days of Future Past as
Marvel prepared to introduce Aaron
Taylor Johnson as The mcu's quicksilver
in Avengers Age of Ultron Fox exercised
its rights to use the character by
casting Evan Peters as the Lightning
Fast mutant for the X-Men prequel sequel
combo the film earned rave reviews and
Peter's Quicksilver was one of its best
parts with one scene in particular
making the headlines Days of Future Past
now iconic super slow-mo kitchen scene
may have looked amazing on film but it
wasn't at all easy to achieve the
sequence had to be shot at a
mind-blowing 3600 frames per second
compare that to The Standard 24 for most
films a frame rate that high requires
huge amounts of light to work in an
interview with i09 Peter said it was
incredibly bright a lot of the crew and
Brian Singer got to wear some sunglasses
and the actors had to keep their eyes
open for a long long time with that
bright light just blaring at you it's
like the sun it's brighter than the sun
it's right there in your eyes but the
end result is so worth it you just power
through it
unlike its predecessor 2016's X-Men
apocalypse didn't go down too well with
the critics still it had a few redeeming
features Chief among which was yeah you
guessed it quicksilver's moment in the
spotlight why mess with perfection right
although technological advances made
between Days of Future Past and
apocalypse made things easier for the
effects team director Brian Singer still
chose to approach quicksilver's second
major set piece as practically as
possible this super slo-mo evacuation
scene may have upped the ante from the
kitchen scene in Days of Future Past but
singer told den of geek that you'd be
surprised just how much of it was real
he explained we did use certain visual
effects certain digital effects and
explosive algorithms but we also took
multiple Phantom 3D cameras and ran them
in protective cases through physical
explosions just because the CGI team had
it easy however doesn't mean everyone
did we blew up our sets we waited until
we were done with them and then blew
them up we flew the cameras through at
80 miles per hour rolling at 3 000
frames per second all in all it took six
weeks to make what amounted to two
minutes of film considering how well
that scene went down with fans however
there's a good chance the crew decided
it was more than worth the effort
the fifth MCU entry marked Chris Evans
debut as Steve Rogers a scrawny New
Yorker who becomes an All-American super
soldier after agreeing to take part in a
military experiment Evans got jacked for
the role though his bulky frame meant
that filming the scenes that take place
before he transforms into Captain
America was very tricky the visual
effects Department shrunk Evan's actual
body for some shots but they also used a
body double actor Leander deeney the
goal was to make the audience fall in
love with a character before he gets any
muscles before he puts on the costume
before he holds his shield visual
effects put Evan's face on leander's
body and although his double was
diligent about mimicking Evan's body
language as best he could the effects
companies still had their work cut out
comparing it to quote taking the head of
a rhinoceros and putting it on the body
of a gazelle
Logan was a milestone movie in Fox's
long-running X-Men franchise not only
because it was Hugh Jackman's final bow
as Wolverine but also because it was the
first time fans got to see the Claude
mutant in all his R-rated Glory the
levels of violence on display during
Logan were like nothing before seen in
the X-Men universe and this meant the
VFX team had their work cut out for them
but Rising Sun Pictures VFX supervisor
Dennis Jones relished the challenge he
told Art of VFX Logan is more brutal
visceral and has direct consequences for
the characters involved the R rating
that was confirmed from the start
introduced another Dynamic to play with
albeit in a restrained fashion in the
Wolverine some of our shots had to be
amended to remove blood and Claw
penetration so it was great to be able
to set the character free from these
constraints
but that Gore went far beyond just
computer Graphics makeup designer Joe
Harlow also told The Verge that the
level of physical trauma in this film is
something I haven't had to contend with
since the early years when I was
smearing blood around
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2's visual
effects supervisor Chris Townsend wasn't
part of the team that worked on the
first Guardians movie but he had
previously worked with Marvel on Captain
America the First Avenger and Iron Man 3
receiving an Oscar nomination for the
latter when offered the opportunity to
oversee the guardian sequel Townsend
jumped at the chance to return to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he told
rotoscopers I'm a huge fan of the films
I think from a creative and visual
effects point of view they're some of
the funnest stuff out there for the
film's Epic third act in which the
Guardians face ego inside his own Planet
Townsend accepted a bid from WETA
digital who picked up the action right
after ego reveals to quill that he gave
his mother cancer what does Guy Williams
told Art of VFX
from that point on it is mostly our work
we go all the way until yondu and quill
rise above the planet as it is destroyed
behind them the new zealand-based visual
effects house had up to 490 staffers
working on Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
at one stage according to Williams who
admitted to losing plenty of sleep over
the highly complicated nature of the
project
let's face it if you're the king of
wakanda you've got to ride in style and
with the world's largest supply of the
miracle metal vibranium at your disposal
a Rolls-Royce or an Air Force One style
Boeing 747 simply won't do luckily those
wakandan engineers and scientists
clearly knew what they were doing when
they designed Black Panther's jet when
King t'challa arrived in wakanda from
his journeys abroad he did so on a
badass super Sleek stealth plane that
looks like it came right out of area 51.
you wouldn't know that if you were just
watching the raw dailies though in the
original footage there was no jet no
Landing platform heck there wasn't even
any wakanda they were just a handful of
actors on a set and a large Blue Screen
in the background
it's a little jarring to see that the
Mad Titan the destroyer of civilizations
the wicked warlord Thanos is actually
well it's Josh Brolin wearing what looks
like an overpriced skin-tight Biker's
outfit while Brolin is probably thankful
he didn't have to wear any space armor
and paint his skin purple for the role
he was still very much present during
the filming of infinity war and end game
thanks to the wonders of motion capture
technology Brolin had never done mocap
before but he saw the light after seeing
what his future Avengers castmate
Benedict Cumberbatch was able to do as
Smaug in The Hobbit the Desolation of
Smaug I kill wherever I please and None
Shall stop me
indeed Brolin's one-on-one interactions
with his castmates added an extra layer
of creepy credibility that made the Mad
Titan that much scarier in the final
movies
one of the most underrated aspects of
Avengers Infinity war was Peter
dinklage's performance as Eatery the
king of the dwarves here the actor who
only stands about four foot four was
playing a 20-foot giant the Lord of the
Rings films famously used forced
perspective to make people look like
hobbit-sized but this film used a
different approach instead having
Dinklage play opposite mini cutouts of
Thor Groot and Rocket Raccoon this makes
dinklage's scene stealing performance
that much more impressive as he was
basically performing with dolls Chris
Hemsworth who also had to act opposite
nothing would shoot his scenes on a set
while Dinklage performed against a blue
screen it's not always easy this acting
malarkey
Infinity War's climactic Battle of
wakanda was filmed on an 8 000 Acre Farm
called Chattahoochee Hills Eventing
about 40 minutes outside Atlanta instead
of thousands of extras only 70
performers were used but they became
more than 500 wakandans digitally and
proceeded to do the battle with thanos's
army of 10 000 alien monsters known as
outriders which were also digitally
produced the art Department even added
indigenous African trees and created an
artificial River for the scene with a
massive pump that was gushing out up to
30 000 gallons per minute that's a lot
of effort for something that's barely
even visible in the finished movie
Thor's arrival at the Battle of wakanda
may very well be the most epic superhero
entrance ever but when you see what it
looked like before the CGI was added
okay it's still pretty epic but it's not
quite the same as the finished product
for this scene Chris Hemsworth donned
his full Thor attire and wielded a
massive ax that just needed a little CG
love to become the mighty Stormbreaker
of course what he didn't have was a
smack talking gun-toting raccoon on his
shoulder an angsty teenage tree hundreds
of wakandan Warriors or an invading Army
of ten thousand alien monsters so yeah
most of the stuff in the scene was added
after the fact all the more reason to be
impressed with Chris Hemsworth's
performance considering he was basically
acting by himself in a ten thousand
dollar Halloween costume following
Hulk's vicious Beatdown at the hands of
Thanos in Avengers Infinity War Marvel
fans were on the edges of their seats
waiting to find out what the future held
for everyone's favorite angry Green
Giant none but the most die-hard comic
book fans would have guessed it would be
Professor Hulk according to animation
boss it was frame store who breathed
life into end games Bruce Banner Hulk
hybrid the process started by taking
Source footage of Mark Ruffalo and
matching it to animation
this animation was then used for 60
shots with headcam footage used for
reference
according to animation supervisor Max
Solomon
it was absolutely about channeling Bruce
Banner his face is very expressive every
Nuance every little Twitch in eye Dart
slight curl of the lip and muscle
tension needed to be translated
VFX supervisor Stuart Penn explained
there was a lot of work involved as
their face shapes are so different Hulk
is massive his mouth proportionally
bigger his eyes are sunk in with deeper
sockets tiny changes to his face had a
huge effect on the performance
having wiped out half of all life in
Infinity War a past version of Thanos
returns to earth in endgame's final act
in a desperate attempt to regain the six
Infinity Stones from The Avengers
unfortunately for him this is the first
time this version of The Mad Titan has
gone up against Captain Marvel
fans had been eagerly anticipating
Captain Marvel's bout against Thanos
ever since she was teased in the
post-credits scene to Avengers Infinity
war after seeing what she was capable of
during both her own movie and her
handful of earlier scenes in endgame it
became clear that the Mad Titan had more
than met his match in Danvers but
bringing this fight to life on set
appears to have been considerably less
epic than how it wound up being on the
big screen but hey that's the magic of
the movies for you
Tony Stark's last stand against Thanos
has to be one of the mcu's greatest ever
scenes
[Music]
Iron Man that final line was a call back
to one first uttered 11 years prior to
end game in Iron Man the film that
launched the biggest franchise in
history and there couldn't have been a
better line for Tony Stark to go out on
strangely enough however it almost
didn't happen during a q a that took
place in the wake of the film's release
the Russo Brothers explained Tony used
to not say anything in that moment and
we were in the editing room going he has
to say something
this is a character who has lived and
died by quips and our editor Jeff Ford
who's been with us all four movies and
is an amazing Storyteller said
why don't we just go full circle with it
and say I am Iron Man and we're like get
the cameras we have to shoot this
tomorrow the scene turned out to be the
last one filmed during end games
reshoots and the behind the scenes
reality of this iconic moment was
thankfully captured by Downey's
assistant Jimmy rich
traditionally horror isn't a genre that
depends on digital trickery taking a
practical approach is often not only
cheaper but more effective when it comes
to unnerving an audience and horror
movies rarely enjoy the freedom of a big
budget especially when the big studios
aren't involved advances in technology
in recent years have made convincing
visual effects far more accessible
however to the point that even low
budget Productions can take advantage
green screens are now commonplace on
horror sets and if you strip away all
the special effects what you're left
with isn't very scary at all Hollow Man
Paul verhoven's hollow man fell well
short of recouping the 95 million dollar
production budget at the domestic box
office and it took a hammering in the
media with 27 on Rotten Tomatoes but
even the harshest critics of the film
admitted that the special effects were
impressive verhoven told DVD talk we
really tried to link the special effects
shots with the actors as much as
possible we wanted coherence between the
special effects and the actors so people
would accept the effects as part of the
actor's scene Jerome Chen senior VFX
supervisor at Sony Pictures imageworks
told FX guide that film was all done
with rotomation off the performance of
Kevin Bacon no motion capture just hard
thousands of hours of Labor
the ring Gore verbinski's box office
smashed the ring kick-started
Hollywood's obsession with Japanese
horror during the mid-2000s Naomi Watts
plays a Seattle journalist who's
investigating an urban legend about a
videotape that kills anyone who watches
it in seven days when her son
unwittingly Pops that tape into their
VHS player the pair are haunted by
Samara who crawls out of a well and
stray through the television but the
look of the vengeful ghost was the
in-camera work of special effects makeup
artist Rick Baker he said I think the
scariest thing about Samara for me
anyways it's not knowing what's under
that hair Crimson Peak Guillermo del
Toro's the shave of water marks a return
to form for the director whose 2015
Gothic romance Crimson Peak tanked hard
at the box office the latter relied on
what VFX supervisor Chris McLean called
practical hybrids for the most part
mixing green screen with creature builds
one example can be seen towards the end
of the movie when Edith has a farewell
moment with Thomas and her fingers
passed right through his face
The Conjuring 2 James wants The
Conjuring in 2013 was the first film and
what would later evolve into a shared
movie Universe encompassing the
Annabelle series as well as the nun and
the Crooked Man visual effects artist
David ridlin worked on a few shots for
the first Conjuring movie rendering some
everyday items that you probably didn't
realize were CGI including this scariest
bed sheet ever VFX artist Didier konings
was hired to take care of the little
details in 2016's The Conjuring 2
removing security cameras and altering
buildings to make the 1970s set look
authentic the thing
on action the Beast comes forward it's
going to be on fire
a prequel to John Carpenter's 1982
horror classic of the same name 2011's
the thing follows the plight of a doomed
group of scientists who discover a
living alien buried deep in a block of
Antarctic Ice the house this
[ __ ] wake up after thousands of
years in the ice
the film's VFX supervisor Jesper
clovesford described his process to the
art of VFX saying as the teeth of the
alien mouth ripped the skin we see the
inside tentacles pushed through while
Juliet's head is forced towards her back
gross
Godzilla director Gareth Edwards landed
on Hollywood's radar with his visually
impressive low budget breakout monsters
in 2010 and the following year he was
offered the job of rebooting Godzilla
Edwards was initially concerned that
signing on for a Hollywood Blockbuster
meant he would have to relinquish
control to a certain extent but the
Studio's reaction to the first teaser
trailer he cut put his mind at ease he
told FX guide I just wanted to do what I
thought would give me goosebumps Edwards
brought in bfx house MPC to make the
trailer and they went on to render
several set pieces in the final film
including Godzilla causing havoc in San
Francisco Bay the shallows survival
horror Thriller the shallow seemed to
come out of nowhere in 2016 going
certified fresh on Rotten Tomatoes The
Predator stalking Blake Lively
throughout the film was created by
brilliantly named important looking
Pirates a Swedish VFX house that
specialized in sharks visual effects
supervisor Scott E Anderson told FSR
most animals sharks included are
designed to blend into the environment
our job is to use visibility selectively
to meet the needs of the film and direct
the audience and I when we want or need
to The Purge election year visual
effects veteran James Hadden has worked
on countless horror franchises over the
years but not have been quite as timely
as 2016's The Purge election year thanks
to haddon's company VFX Legion viewers
were able to experience another
frightening night on the Lawless streets
of oblique near future America though
for the actors involved many of those
scenes were created in post according to
Heaven his priority on a project like
this one is delivering value for money
he told Freight find horror movies do
not have huge budgets and so the idea
that CG is going to be in your horror
movie it's really hard to do because
they're not funded to do that Adam went
on to explain that it's his personal
policy to make sure that any shots his
company is responsible for don't look
cheap even if they are cheap by
Blockbuster standards adding my goal in
delivering shots out of VFX Legion to
the world is that they should not bump
in the cut
Prometheus a number of VFX houses worked
on Ridley Scott's 2012 return to the
alien franchise including MPC fuel VFX
Luma pictures and WETA digital the new
zealand-based company was tasked with
rendering the film's new race of giant
humanoid extraterrestrials which
involved digitally enhancing the onset
performance of a costumed actor what
does VFX supervisor Martin Hill said
usually we would strive to make a Digi
character as anatomically accurate as
possible in terms of its musculature
articulation and the thickness and
pliability of the fat Under the Skin we
had to make some compromises to match an
actor in Silicon Prosthetics designing
the look of the engineers was a job that
fell to concept artist Neville page he
told wired that when Scott first
approached him the director envisioned
the engineers as a mixture between some
well-known statues and one legendary
musician Paige said Scott had specific
metaphors in mind for the artist telling
wired I was looking at reference of
Statue of Liberty the the Michelangelo
sculptures specifically David and oddly
Elvis Presley
World War Z when he sat down to discuss
his team's achievements with wired World
War Z visual effects supervisor Scott
Ferrar explained that it was always
their intention to break from the
traditional zombie mode with this movie
they went with a scientific approach
Reckoning that a real virus of this
nature would make humans fast vicious
and Relentless the biggest example is
the Epic moment when 8500 computer
animated zombies pile on top of each
other to breach the walls of Israel
Farrar said the single hardest thing
about that was just making those piles
look right without something going wrong
you're always battling with what looks
good and cool in a movie and still feels
real you can look at these shots every
day for months and then all of the
sudden you're almost ready to go to
final and somebody will spot something
that's wrong in the shot it's like
where's Waldo while CGI clearly played a
massive part in bringing this world to
life animation director Andrew Jones
favored a mixture of computer graphics
and practical performances hiring
talented contortionists who could mimic
the semi-possessed look they were going
for
Krampus to promote their work on the
2015 Christmas horror movie Krampus
wetter released a mock interview with
the film's chief gingerbread Handler who
claimed working with the gingerbread man
on set was a real challenge they were
easily startled and fragile and really
skittish in reality they were one of the
smaller challenges what a faced on the
project which was approached in a
largely practical fashion for sake of
nostalgia wetta Workshop co-founder
Richard Taylor said this is a classic
80s monster movie this is fantastic
stuff this is what we live for this is
what gets us up in the morning from the
animatronic cherub that attacks Tony
Collette in the attic to the terrifying
Jack-in-the-Box operated from inside by
three puppeteers Krampus minions were as
ingenious as they were unnerving and
none more so than the anti-claws himself
the titular demon was portrayed by Luke
Hawker who wore a custom-made costume
complete with hoof stilts and prosthetic
finger extensions he said of the heavy
suit a muscles that are just burning and
you're sweating and you're thinking am I
going to throw up and then Mike comes in
and his the smile on his face just says
it all I Am Legend the Will Smith LED
adaptation of Richard Matheson's seminal
zombie novel I Am Legend did pretty well
with the critics and didn't disappoint
at the box office but it's widely
accepted that the CGI sucked the film
was fast-tracked into production before
a script had even been completed and the
schedule started to get backed up when
the Practical creature effects looked
terrible on camera the decision was made
to render the undead digitally though in
reality there was never enough time to
make them look convincing director
Francis Lawrence told den of geek it was
better than doing the live versions at
that time because it didn't work but we
needed six more months on the post end
to get all the visual effects right
because there were some close-ups that
were stunning and then you get some
shots that I never got right and it just
kills it one of the big downfalls for me
with that movie Personally was with the
visual effects VFX supervisor Yannick
Sears told awn that the animators were
still redesigning the creatures during
post-production to match the quote
continually evolving nature of the film
deadly honeymoon even if you consider
yourself a true Gore Hound chances are
you've never heard of deadly honeymoon
this low budget TV movie from 2010
probably would have flown under the
radar altogether had it not been based
on true events that took place five
years earlier a story that grab news
headlines and became the subject of a
dateline report in 2005 newlywed George
Smith and his bride Jennifer set sail on
their dream Honeymoon Cruise though only
one of them would survive the groom
simply vanished one night a mystery that
has never been solved lifetime adapted
the story into a television feature
changing the names and creating their
own explanation they cast Summer Glau in
the role of wife turned Widow Lindsay
which was a dream come true according to
the actress she told my San Antonio I've
wanted to do a lifetime movie since I
was a little girl it's a really good way
for girls to get challenging dramatic
roles her faith in the network was
rewarded when they hired an experienced
VFX crew to turn the set into the open
ocean
computer generated effects are
ubiquitous in Hollywood so when
something amazing happens on screen
audiences usually assume they're seeing
a digital fantasy but despite the search
in CGI some directors are still
committed to doing special effects the
old-fashioned way before today's digital
Wizardry existed from puppets to
Prosthetics to old-school camera tricks
we've rounded up some of the most insane
scenes you'll never believe were created
without computers flipping out fact
director Christopher Nolan actively
dislikes CGI and believes that audiences
prefer the real thing as much as he does
so he uses practical effects in his
films whenever possible remember that
epic car chase in the Dark Knight that
ended with a giant 18-wheeler going butt
over tea kettle right in the middle of
an actual city block
thank you
special effects Genies use computers to
edit out some of the equipment involved
in the stunts but everything else was
completely real aided by a remote
controlled piston that was installed in
the truck to propel its rear off the
ground the scene was filmed from seven
different angles because when you're
making an 18-wheeler do a somersault in
the middle of the night in downtown
Chicago there is no such thing as take
two anti-gravity fisticus The Dark
Knight director didn't limit his
commitment to practical effects only to
his Batman franchise which don't forget
also included blasting a plane in half
mid-air
plan
crashing this flood
in Inception Nolan and his team created
The gravity-defying Dream Within A Dream
fight scene by channeling none other
than talented singer and hat Enthusiast
Jamiroquai and built a hundred foot long
hotel hallway on a rotating set
according to actor Joseph Gordon-Levitt
the filming process required as much
mental flexibility as it did acrobatic
balance telling E online I had to think
of it like this is the ground okay now
this is the ground and now this is the
ground it was just that the ground was
always moving under me that was the mind
game I had to play to make it work with
a camera mounted on a track that ran the
length of the set Nolan was able to
create seamless stable shots even as the
hallway itself spun 360 degrees but
Nolan wasn't the one who invented the
old rotating room the blood-bathing bed
CGI wasn't much of an option back in
1984 especially for a low budget horror
flick like Wes Craven's Nightmare on Elm
Street so when Craven's horror franchise
introduced audiences to the original
Fedora wearing monster it had to pull
off its nightmarish special effects the
old-fashioned way these days the
soul-sucking blood geyser that consumed
Johnny Depp would probably be done with
computers but for the original nightmare
the effects team came up with an
inventive way to pull it off the bedroom
set was built on a rotating axis which
could be turned a full 360 degrees what
you see is actually an upside down set
once the bedroom was flipped all they
had to do was pour 500 gallons of fake
blood through the bed and let gravity do
the rest uh simple right men becoming
wolves An American Werewolf in London
featured animatronic heads prosthetic
body parts and the most elaborate
assortment of merkins in the history of
film werewolf iconic transformation
scene was achieved with nothing but good
old-fashioned practical effects and the
magic of Rick Baker the effects Guru
created prosthetic versions of actor
David Norton's limbs then fitted them
with air bladders to make them deform as
Norton's character turned from man to
Wolf for the facial transformation to
animatronic heads created the illusion
of the actor's head reshaping itself
into something more wolf-like and the
Furry Overcoat that effect used the
latex skin threaded with thousands and
thousands of wiry hairs Baker filmed the
hair being pulled backwards through the
skin then reversed the sharp to
stimulate rapid growth the final result
was so realistic and terrifying that it
earned its creator the 1982 Academy
Award for best makeup and when the movie
got its inevitable 21st century reboot
in the form of An American Werewolf in
Paris the terrible CGI effects couldn't
hold a candle to this practical Wizardry
the killer T-Rex hold on to your butts
there's a reason the Lizard King of
Jurassic Park was such an imposing
presence he was a real life full-sized
animatronic that nearly killed someone
on set the T-Rex weighed 9 000 pounds
and was built on a skeleton made of
hydraulic motors and moving metal Parts
he was also decidedly dangerous during
the production a crew member was unlucky
enough to be stuck inside the belly of
the Beast during a power outage sending
thousands of pounds of hydraulics
crushing down on him fortunately he
lived to tell the tale even the digital
dinosaurs of Jurassic Park were often a
combination of CGI and puppetry for
instance the Brachiosaurus that sneezed
all over Lex was only a Digi saw from
the neck down the head was all real for
most of its time on screen as was the
copious spray of dinosnut much to the
dismay of actress Ariana Richards little
Hobbit's Big World rather than rely
completely on post-production CGI to
shrink Elijah Wood or ambigan Ian
McAllen Peter Jackson often used old
school optical illusions to make his
Hobbits teeny tiny in comparison to all
the Wizards Orcs And elves of Middle
Earth using camera angles cropping and
the actor's relative positioning the
effect known as Force perspective makes
them appear to be differently sized than
they actually are in theory it's simple
in practice it meant that many shots had
to be staged down to the millimeter
throughout the entire Lord of the Rings
trilogy as well as The Hobbit trilogy a
decade later
liquid metal evil in 1991 Terminator 2
was a groundbreaking example of the
power of digital effects boasting CGI
that went miles beyond anything else
that had been done however what made the
movie so spectacular wasn't the CGI
alone but the way James Cameron
seamlessly integrated the computer
animated Cuts with practical effects for
every purely digital shot of T1000
slithering around in a liquid metal form
there was a scene rendered the
old-fashioned way with puppets and
expert camera work giving the film a
sense of real world weight most
incredibly every time the T-1000 was
blasted apart Stan Winston's special
effects team would bring in a mangled
metallic puppet complete with a cast of
actor Robert Patrick's head to thrash
around in the t-1000s last moments the
blown up puppet is so seamlessly
intricate with motion capture effects
that you can't even tell where one ends
and the other begins
you simply can't make a superhero film
without relying on the work of visual
effects artists to some degree but the
level of Reliance in the modern age has
reached Heights that it can be difficult
to really understand unless you see the
original footage with your own eyes
Christopher Nolan is known for taking a
practical approach to effects whenever
possible but even he turns to the VFX
team from time to time visual effects
co-supervisor Dan glass revealed that
the movie had nearly 600 effects shots
one of the most challenging jobs at
glass and his partner Yannick serves
faced was making the Batmobile look
convincing which they achieved through a
mixture of trick shots and Miniatures
the Miniatures they created weren't
actually that many at all they made a
three-quarter scale 5-foot Batmobile
glass explained the key with Miniatures
is scale and Yannick pushed hard to use
large Miniatures some were 35 feet tall
uk-based visual effects house double
negative completed half of the 600
effects shots in the movie and it was
nominated at the visual effects Society
awards for its efforts
[Music]
so what do you think
does it come in Black
Keanu Reeves's relationship with the
Hollywood press has always been love
hate 2005's Constantine was one of the
hate moments as the majority of movie
critics bashed the supernatural DC flick
the film suffered from a fundamental
change deep into production according to
Deke ferrand hatch FX co-founder and
Lead map painter he explained we began
working on Constantine in April of 2004.
the original delivery was set for the
end of July however in mid-july as we
were finalizing the final Composites
there was a drastic change in Direction
which resulted in starting a new concept
phase
fans of the Green Lantern first started
to worry about the adaptation when they
discovered that Hal Jordan's suit was to
be made entirely from CGI so that the
VFX teams would have some flexibility
with the design Ryan Reynolds wore
tracking suits and all the effects were
added in after filming so how they did
that was using a motion capture suit
which has all these dots and these look
like a crash test dummy in the end the
suit itself was passable but the
unnatural looking mask wound up ruining
the overall effect while many people
pointed to the substandard CGI Reynolds
blamed the script for the film's
failings revealing that it hadn't even
been written when he signed on to Star
he told Yahoo when we shot Green Lantern
nobody auditioning for the role of Green
Lantern was given the opportunity to
read the script because the script
didn't exist in the end most audiences
had the same reaction
ah green
three years after debuting as the man of
steel Henry Cavill was back in the red
cape and facing off against Ben
Affleck's Batman according to scanline's
VFX supervisor Brian hirota director
Zack Snyder came to him with an idea for
a montage that showed Superman saving
people all over the world which he
wanted to intercut with news stations
debating whether or not the Kryptonian
was welcome on Earth Henry Cavill was
digitally dropped into numerous
dangerous situations and natural
disasters one of which was a huge flood
while the finished product looks pretty
convincing it turns out it was shot on
an asphalt Backlot in Michigan hirota
told Art to VFX in post we used our
flowline software to simulate the river
and debris going around the houses we
extended the environment with added
extra houses trees and distant mountain
ranges after that it was simply a matter
of dropping Superman into the mix and
just like that you have a disastrous
flood
it bombed hard with critics but DC's
anti-hero Ensemble Suicide Squad still
made a ton of money a lot of visual
effects went into the film so much that
the load had to be divided between 17
different VFX houses one such company
was MPC whose workload included Harley
Quinn's elevator fight scene NPC visual
effects supervisor Seth Mori told Art of
VFX plates were shot of Harley fighting
with a practical actor our goal was to
replace the heads on these practical
actors so that the eyes on the head were
alive and blinking during each shot and
so that the head breathed and pulsed
Mori revealed that his favorite part of
the sequence was blowing up these heads
every one of which was unique down to
the Last Detail
the DC extended Universe was given a
breath of fresh air with Wonder Woman
the film looked great thanks in no small
part to the work of effects companies
like MPC who contributed around 500
visual effects shots led by bfx
supervisor Jessica Norman the MBC team
helped create the Epic Beach battle the
No Man's Land sequence and several other
action scenes the company's website
reveals the beach battle sequence was
shot on the west coast of Italy across
two beaches NPC's environmental artists
extended the beach and added Cliff
backdrops Cliffs and Islands were lit
and rendered by mpc's lighting team NPC
also developed quotes new controls for
hair simulations to be able to maintain
the shape and style of Wonder Woman's
hair in these action-packed scenes there
was a time when an actor's hair was the
responsibility of makeup alone but in
the age of superhero Blockbusters every
strand is subject to scrutiny from the
visual effects Department
while it might not have lived up to the
standard set by Wonder Woman Justice
League still fared better with the
critics than the first three films in
the franchise the movie seemed destined
to fail after Zack Snyder left the
project before the shoot was done Marvel
stalwart Joss Whedon stepped in to
finish the film but the result was a
hodgepodge of styles that didn't work as
well as Warner Brothers might have
imagined the film's visual effects would
become a huge talking point especially
when it was revealed that Warner
Brothers was forced to digitally remove
a mustache that Henry Cavill had grown
for Mission Impossible Fallout because
Paramount refused to let him shave it
for Justice League reshoots it comes and
goes some of the CGI on cabell's upper
lip was downright awful with his mouth
looking particularly deformed in the
film's opening moments an unnamed
Justice League VFX artist said it
shouldn't have been improved internally
let alone gone all the way to make it
into the film I don't even know what
they say about mustaches easy to lose if
you dig around
it's usually close by
when George Lucas came up with the idea
of Star Wars in the mid-1970s setting an
adventure of this scope in outer space
had never been done before so how did he
get the film to look so good when there
were no visual effects companies up to
the challenge at the time he started his
own industrial Light and Magic was
formed to handle the special effects in
Star Wars and they're still
revolutionizing the industry with their
work let's peek behind the scenes at
what Star Wars movies look like before
they work their magic
A New Hope
the original trilogy is known for its
use of practical effects but in truth
those films relied on visual trickery
just as much as their successors
sprawling CGI backgrounds were not an
option when the first Star Wars movie
was being made so the effects artists at
ilm came up with some ingenious
Alternatives matte glass paintings were
painstakingly created by hand and then
added to scenes later but a different
technique was needed to bring the
movie's many spaceships to life former
ilm front man John Dykstra told den of
geek back in the days of Star Wars we
kind of walked into an empty warehouse
and sat on the floor and went how are we
going to do this The Producers Gary
Kurtz of fox and George Lucas took an
incredible Risk by listening to what
myself and my collaborators had to say
with regard to how to do this because we
were inventing this stuff from scratch
when it came to Han Solo's Millennium
Falcon Dykstra decided to create a model
and film it in front of a blue screen
using an early computer-controlled
camera which allowed his team to add all
of the outer space details in post
The Empire Strikes Back Dykstra and his
team won an Oscar for their
revolutionary work on Star Wars but
Lucas chose not to bring Dykstra along
when he moved his base of operations to
San Francisco it was here that ilm got
to work on the next movie but despite
the success of the first film budget
restraints were still a problem when it
came to making The Empire Strikes Back
as VFX supervisor Richard Edlund later
pointed out computer Graphics were
extremely expensive very slow and the
resolution was always a problem luckily
for edland and Lucas the team they'd
assembled proved more than capable of
delivering results within their means
the film's cinematographer mark Virgo
compared this era in cinematic history
to the lunar program referring to the
period as an amazing Cooperative of
artists imagination Optics engineering
and homebrewed software
Return of the Jedi by the time 1983's
Return of the Jedi went into production
the ilm crew had found their groove
Master of Puppets Phil Tippett was
brought in to head up the Creature Shop
that ultimately created the Ewoks and
the rest of the effects work was divided
between Richard edland Ken Ralston and
Dennis Muran among the jobs that failed
Muran was the Speeder Bike Chase one of
the hardest sequences in the film with
100 total effect shots mirin explained
because the bikes were going to be blue
screen the backgrounds didn't require
that many different shots to do because
we could use them over and over again I
got the idea to do it with a Steadicam I
called Garrett brownup who invented it
and he flew out from back east and we
did a test out in Samuel Taylor Park out
here with him just walking along with
the camera shooting one frame a second
and the thing worked Muller and brown
spent several days in the woods just
filming trees from different angles then
matched the footage up when they went
back to the studio to film the actors in
front of the blue screens
The Phantom Menace George Lucas's
long-awaited return to the Star Wars
Universe didn't fail financially but it
did let down a number of fans who were
quick to turn on new CGI character Jar
Jar Binks despite the overwhelmingly
negative reaction to the character Ahmed
best the man who played the gungan is
proud of the fact that he broke new
ground with jar jar he explained one of
the biggest reasons I took it was
because of the challenge of it it hadn't
been done before there was no Andy
Circus in Gollum no Navi from Avatar I
was working with George to Pioneer this
new character form of acting and
storytelling unlike best the actor who
played Darth Maul only has fond memories
of The Phantom Menace his first
experience on a movie set martial artist
and actor Ray Park was initially only
brought in to film some test footage but
Lucas liked this work so much that he
decided to cast him as the Sith Lord
Park's primary fighting style is wushu
but he also practiced gymnastics in
ballet in preparation for his big fights
scene with Obi-Wan Kenobi and Qui-Gon
Jinn once the choreography was worked
out the scene was filmed in front of a
custom blue set and handed off to ilm
just one of the many sequences they were
required to complete attack of the
Clones
the ongoing advances in CGI meant that
Lucas could set stories in parts of his
Galaxy that were previously inaccessible
which he took full advantage of in
Attack of the Clones he explained that
was the fun part of writing the project
I wasn't limited whatever my imagination
could come up with I would just put down
on the page and say we'll worry about
this later animation director Rob
Coleman was initially under the
impression that some of the cityscapes
and backgrounds Lucas required for
episode 2 were going to have some
practical elements but he soon learned
this wasn't the case of the 2 000
effects shots and attack of the Clones
around half include completely
computer-generated characters a team of
60 animators worked alongside 340 ilm
artists and technicians to render some
of the most well-known Star Wars faces
in CGI including a certain little green
Jedi Master Rob Coleman explained the
biggest technical challenge for me was
animating Yoda that was due to Frank Oz
having created that character in The
Empire Strikes Back In is a puppet this
time Yoda is much more active and
prominent he actually runs and has a
lightsaber battle Yoda's duel with Count
Dooku was one of the film's big visual
effects set pieces but it required some
human input from Christopher Lee who was
one of the many cast members forced to
work with blue screens for long periods
of time Revenge of the Sith
according to Ian McDermott who played
Chief Palpatine the use of green screen
was really ramped up for the third and
final film in the Lucas prequel trilogy
which had the most effect shots yet he
told the telegraph so much of the
filming took place in front of a green
screen I used to feel great sympathy for
Ewan and Hayden because they had so much
fighting to do and quite often had to
fight imagined enemies George often
hadn't decided on the details of the
film so Ewan and Hayden didn't know if
they were filming an ironic moment or
whether they were about to die episode 3
also introduced us to General Grievous
the lightsaber wielding cyborg who held
the title of supreme commander of the
droid army during the Clone Wars upon
receiving the design for the character
animation director Rob Coleman knew ilm
were going to have a tough job breathing
life into this one he explained since
his movement was so restricted we
decided to have him talk with his hands
because although there is a grill
pattern where his mouth should be there
are no articulating bits for his mouth
no lip sync or facial expressions no
brow to move no indication of what he is
feeling or thinking Grievous wasn't the
only villain without eyebrows in this
movie it's in episode 3 that we get to
see Anakin Skywalker become Darth Vader
after he's badly burned in a battle with
Obi-Wan a scene which had its own
effects challenges Hayden Christensen
wasn't originally going to be the person
in the icon suit but in the end he
convinced Lucas to let him play the part
I begged and pleaded and they were nice
enough to build a Darth Vader suit that
actually fit me the force awakens after
working with JJ Abrams on his Star Trek
reboot visual effects supervisor Roger
guyette joined the director going into
the force awakens and the Paris
partnership proved as fruitful as ever
episode 7 made over 2 billion dollars
globally while Gaia and his team were
nominated for an Academy Award for their
work much of which Incorporated
practical effects in particular Real
Models were often used for the little
bb-8 Droid Gaia told Art of VFX from the
beginning we knew we wanted bb-8 to be
as practical as possible so that the
actors could interact with him and of
course JJ could direct him on set
removing the puppeteers from Shots later
on proved tricky but guyet had nothing
but praise for them despite all the
effort that went into making bb-8 real
there were still a number of scenes in
which the character had to be rendered
digitally out of necessity around a
third of all shots in fact obviously
some of the characters couldn't just be
done physically and in those occasions
JJ was more than happy to push the
digital technology of fully digital
actors for all the Practical work guide
estimates that the force awakens
contains around 2 100 effect shots
Rogue one a Star Wars Story the first
Star Wars spin-off went in a New
Direction in terms of both narrative and
style and most critics were impressed
with the result one of the major talking
points was the digital resurrection of
Peter Cushing as Grand Moff Tarkin whose
character was portrayed by guy Henry the
emotion capture VFX supervisor John Noel
was able to track down a cast of
Cushing's face made for the 1984 movie
Top Secret which gave them a huge Head
Start when it came to recreating the
late actors likeness the process took a
whopping 18 months to complete and was
done with the permission of Cushing's
estate of course Tarkin wasn't the only
CG character in Rogue one to create the
Droid k2so the filmmakers fitted Alan
Tudyk with a motion capture suit and
then digitally added the robot's body
later to get tudik's face at the
appropriate level for the Towering robot
they took two different approaches in
some scenes tudik Wars stilts while he
interacted with the other actors if the
shot was dangerous to you stilts he wore
a backpack with a paper cut out of k2's
head positioned several feet above his
own now that's dedication there's no way
to respect this you know the Last Jedi
JJ Abrams spoke at length about using as
many practical effects as possible in
the force awakens in order to recreate
the feeling of the original trilogy and
his successor Ryan Johnson adopted the
same attitude when he took the reins for
The Last Jedi Neil Scanlon returned to
head up the Creature Shop and this time
they were tasked with creating a new
breed of animal called a vulptex a
fox-like inhabitant of the planet crate
Scanlan told Entertainment Weekly the
idea is that these wonderful sort of
feral creatures had lived on this planet
and had consumed the planet's surface
and as such had become crystalline to
get an idea of how such a creature might
move they fitted a small dog with a suit
adorned with drinking straws The Next
Step was creating an animatronic puppet
that the cast could interact with in
scenes but much like the bb-8 build it
wasn't possible to use it 100 of the
time
static models complete with 25
000 individual crystals were built for
the benefit of the VFX team who were
able to scan them and render the
creatures however Johnson wanted
over the years computer-generated
effects have become an increasingly
crucial tool in Hollywood's Arsenal but
there's a right way and a wrong way to
handle them while some movies use CGI as
a gentle paintbrush others have
clobbered audiences over the head with
it resulting in big budget
disappointment not all the movies in
this list are Clunkers but if the
digital effects were a little bit better
they might have been better received
here are some movies that were all but
ruined by their special effects
I Am Legend
this 2007 movie put Will Smith as the
Lone Survivor of a zombie ruled World
aside from his trusty canine Smith
spends the first 40 minutes of the movie
totally alone then the dark Seekers show
up and ruin everything director Francis
Lawrence didn't intend to use CGI for
the dark Seekers he wanted to rely on
actors and practical effects but when it
came time to shoot the movie the effects
weren't convincing with no time to make
Corrections he had to resort to CGI he
would later describe the CGI compromise
as a major disappointment in a
conversation with den of geek when I saw
the dailies I broke out into a cold
sweat they were very pale and covered in
this chalky powder to protect their skin
which was a really interesting concept
but it looked like a bunch of mime
artists running across Washington Square
Park it didn't work at all
the thing
John Carpenter's The Thing is a
masterpiece of practical effects with
body horror sequences that still look
frighteningly good to this day the same
cannot be said for the things 2011
prequel while the filmmakers work to
make the story fit with Carpenter's
chronology the movie's special effects
don't hold a candle to what the 1982
version accomplished
that's not to say they didn't try the
production hired special effects house
Studio ADI to bring the gooey gross
monsters to life unfortunately due to
problems with scheduling and budget many
of the company's practical effects
didn't show up in the movie according to
Bloody Disgusting the film was such a
disaster that studio ADI later
fan-funded a film called Harbinger down
which was made as an apology for what
happened in 2011.
Tron legacy the majority of the special
effects in the 2010 Tron sequel are
pretty great except for the CGI face of
a young Jeff Bridges as the movie's
villain clue despite best efforts the
de-aged bridges looked off a Time
Magazine review summed up the issues
saying he looks just like young Bridges
if young Bridges had had way too much
plastic surgery so it's hard to take him
seriously clue seems more like an
unfortunate Botox victim than a
dastardly despot
Green Lantern before Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds suited up for DC as Hal Jordan
aka Green Lantern the first film in a
planned franchise for the glowing green
hero those plans didn't pan out people
came to see the Green Lantern but what
they got was mostly green screen while
Reynolds told Yahoo movies that the
script was to blame for the film's
failure the mediocre wall-to-wall CGI
didn't help a review from screen crush
went in on the movie's fatal floss
saying almost nothing on screen is real
up to and including the sense of
adventure it's just a bunch of digital
stuff shooting other digital stuff and
some of that digital stuff looks really
bad
oh
[Music]
The Matrix Reloaded in 1999 The Matrix
was a special effects Marvel but when
the Matrix Reloaded hit theaters just a
few years later CGI took the driver's
seat the high-tech wire work and
practical effects that made the original
so jaw-dropping were washed out in a sea
of CGI that looked iffy and aged poorly
this issue is most apparent during the
movie's Infamous Burley brawl scene a
sequence that found Keanu Reeves Neo
battling hundreds of agent Smiths the
concept probably jumped off the page but
the finished product of the Burley brawl
is really more of a mushy mess
The Mummy Returns when the sequel to The
Mummy hit theaters in 2001 digital
effects were still very much in their
infancy but that didn't stop this movie
from leaning into the spectacle like a
cake that isn't quite done cooking yet
the effects look rubbery and half-baked
and they've aged even more poorly than
the mummy itself this was Dwayne
Johnson's first foray into the big
budget world of blockbuster movies being
introduced as the villainous Scorpion
King unfortunately the people's champ
ended up looking more like a video game
villain when he showed up for his
climactic fight scene it would have been
impressive on the PlayStation 2 but on
the big screen not even close
foreign
[Music]
character-driven take on the Hulk has
its supporters but the movie's special
effects are far from incredible the
dissolve discussing the Marvel movie
noted that the effects used to create
the halt kept hitting the limits of what
2003 CGI could accomplish making the
monster look more like a work of
Animation than green flesh and blood
when Lee's Hulk hit theaters the MCU was
just a twinkle in Marvel's eye Lee did
the best with what he had but at the end
of the day Hulk's Green Giant left us
pining for the good old days of Lou
Ferrigno and all his body painted Glory
at least that get up felt real
foreign
there are movies with little to no
special effects movies with a moderate
amount movies with a lot of them and
then there's Zack Snyder's Justice
League if you want to know what Justice
League looked like before all those
effects were added here's a peek behind
the scenes
the first mother box Steppenwolf comes
after is in possession of the Amazon's
Infamous Kira in a heavily guarded
Temple it's the first time we see the
horned villain in the film and when he
lands via a portal he has no qualms
about slinging these women left and
right as they battle him without fear
Queen hippolyta realizes she has to take
the mother box out and seal the temple
despite knowing several of her fellow
Amazons will die in the process as she
escapes through a tunnel awaiting Amazon
Warriors stand by with large hammers
ready to knock out massive Stone pillars
which will release several walls and
trap all inside hopefully killing
Steppenwolf in the process in reality we
know that these Amazons are just hitting
large foam pillars wrapped in green
cloth as this HBO Max behind the scenes
clip reveals
in part two of the film Diana Prince
gives Bruce Wayne a five-minute lesson
on the Golden Age of Heroes and their
battle against Darkseid while the
audience is treated to a visual Montage
of the whole shebang we see atlanteans
the old gods a Green Lantern Amazons and
Men battle against Darkseid and his
Armada in an all-out War
bodies are flying all over the place in
this scene as almost everyone except men
can launch themselves into the air with
ease there is one shot of an unknown
Amazon who climbs on top of her horse
before jumping into the air to wreak
havoc on some paradisements in a behind
the scenes clip we can see that her
horse is not real at all and neither is
the world around her
when Steppenwolf comes for the second
mother box he has to look for it in the
ocean as it's being guarded underwater
by atlanteans Mira is one of the first
atlanteans to challenge Steppenwolf and
fights him off as he tries to steal the
Box Steppenwolf gets the upper hand and
almost wipes her out entirely before
Aquaman shows up to save the day yet
again
an underwater fight sequence isn't easy
as this behind the scenes clip proves
three crew members had to help sling
Jason Momoa around in the air as he hung
from wires to make his movement look
effortless as if he was truly underwater
just before the team revives Superman
they have to break into Star Labs so
they have the entire Place evacuated
with false alarm put in place by cyborg
Victor struts down one of the walkways
carrying a mother box when he passes his
father Dr Silas Stone Silas is trying to
alert the evacuated staff that the alarm
was actually false when he sees his son
is up to something and ends up going
along with the plan in a behind the
scenes clip it looks like the scene was
filmed without green screens as Ray
Fisher Dons his motion capture suit
fitted with two red glowing lights and
walks down the corridor with his father
just behind him
doomsday decapitated Superman's head
from his monument in Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice and it was never
reconstructed the revived Superman ends
up using this head as a weapon against
the Justice League but it's not as
effective as he might have hoped as he
picks up the head with ease Superman
launches it directly at Wonder Woman Who
slices it in half with her sword like
she's cutting a piece of cake it's
interesting to see in this behind the
scenes photo which Henry Cavill posted
to his Instagram that the green prop
version still resembled ahead
later in the big Showdown after he
blocks Wonder Woman's attack Superman
pulls her arms apart and headbutts her
she fires one right back at him which
takes him a second to recover from after
he's had enough Superman delivers the
headbutt of all headbutts when he lifts
himself in the air and comes down on
Wonder Woman Like a ton of bricks in
order to get this scene perfect a green
screen covered crew member had to Aid
Henry Cavill by bending his legs in a
way which brought more fluidity to his
body while he was held up with wires it
would have been impossible for Cavill to
bend his body this way while up on the
wires so the silly looking crew member
was essential to get it just right
it turns out that one of the movie's key
outdoor scenes was actually filmed
outside if you can believe it after
Clark Kent sees Lois Lane and is
reminded of who he is the duo flies off
to his family's foreclosed farm and
spends some time in the field getting
reacquainted while the white farmhouse
was real the massive tree and
surrounding buildings we see in the
movie aren't large green screens were
used so additional buildings could be
added in as well as a few oversized
leafless trees we had seen these extra
buildings before in Man of Steel where
Clark's father Jonathan Kent hid his
crashed Kryptonian ship after the boy
first landed on Earth throughout Zack
Snyder's Justice League we see Bruce
Wayne Cyborg and Alfred work on the
Flying Fox the jet Bruce constructed as
a Troop Carrier the team had some issues
getting it to fly but eventually the jet
is in working order and carries the team
across the world to take on Steppenwolf
Bruce mans the Flying Fox alone after
dropping the team off on land and takes
down steppenwolf's force field allowing
everyone to enter and start smashing
skulls while it looks like Affleck
really is in some type of aircraft in
the movie he's actually sitting in a
wooden approximation of the ship's
cockpit that remains stationary and he
has to thrust himself around to make it
look like he's actually in motion ah
movie Magic
[Music]
Disney's live-action remakes have
dazzled audiences around the world but
it takes a lot of work to make these
movies as visually impressive as they
are don't believe it take a look at how
these Disney live-action remakes look
without the CGI
the visual effects Wizards at MPC spent
two long years building the wild dense
World Of The Jungle Book the vast
majority of which was created digitally
VFX supervisor Adam Valdez told
animation World Network when they came
to us wanting to do the movie with blue
screen and one kid it was daunting the
company had a team from its Bangalore
office visit 50 different jungle
locations around India to conduct
research for the project they came back
with hundreds of thousands of reference
photos as well as plenty of animal
footage for the visual effects team to
work with but creating the movie's
photorealistic animals wasn't even the
hard part making Bagheera and Baloo's
interactions with Mowgli feel genuine
was what would ultimately make or break
John favreau's live-action remake of The
Jungle Book and the MPC team knew that
all too well Valdez explains the guys in
the rigging Department spent many months
developing and researching facial
Anatomy on big cats wolves and bears as
well as how they move in the end it was
an astute suggestion from the director
that made all the difference according
to Valdez John had this brilliant idea
of using Jim Henson company puppet tears
to work with Neil seti the actor who
plays Mowgli so that he always had him
moving an engaging puppet a young person
leaves that to the imagination and it
came through
the visual effects artist working on The
Jungle Book were also aware that a lot
was riding on the appearance of the
story's antagonist Shir Khan how long
did you really think you'd survive
against me the human-hating tiger was
just a guy in a blue leotard on set but
NPC's team of animators had to turn him
into a fearsome villain according to the
company's VFX supervisor Adam Valdez the
challenge was in creating animals that
were capable of conveying emotion while
still looking completely natural he told
Arda bfx we can all relate to some
things like when a deer reacts with
fright we understand that but how does a
tiger sit down with intimidating
attitude Valdez and his team were on a
constant hunt for references as they
built cheer Khan from scratch he
explained many clips of animal movements
were found recreated and then dialed
into the shots the animators spent a lot
of time on the shots adding delicate
little touches of course movement is
only one aspect of making a convincing
CGI animal but Valdez was never that
concerned about the fur MPC has so much
experience with rendering animals that
the company has its very own proprietary
tool fertility Valdez says it's quite
powerful and I think we have the best
hair and fur in the business
to make it easier for Beauty and the
Beast director Bill Condon to get a grip
on a CGI heavy movie Disney decided to
make the experience as physical as
possible bfx supervisor Kyle McCulloch
told deadline we have the special
effects team build some of the
characters as animatronics so they could
actually be animated and moved around on
set we had life-size builds of them that
we could have on set and then we had
puppets the Beast was originally going
to be achieved using practical effects
alone according to McCulloch the two VFX
vendors hired to work on the Remake
discussed using a mixture of makeup and
animatronics but in the end the
flexibility of the CGI option was just
too tempting to pass up they also needed
to make sure that the Fidelity of the
actor's performance wasn't lost by going
digital they would be able to take the
nuance and subtleties of Dan Stevens
performance and reflect them in the
Beast himself according to McCulloch if
you were trying to do it under a
thousand pounds of makeup it was never
going to give us the clarity of
performance at digital domain ultimately
achieved in beast when Disney decided to
remake 1977's Pete's Dragon it turned to
a bender with a proven track record of
bringing fantasy creatures to life wet
at digital WETA has created some of the
most memorable CGI characters in movie
history and has worked with motion
capture Legend Andy Circus on multiple
occasions circus won praised for his
portrayal of evolved chimpanzee Caesar
in the Planet of the Apes reboot series
and what it took inspiration from that
character when it came to making Pete's
titular Dragon Elliot as well as Eric
Sandman told The Hollywood Reporter with
Caesar you really feel his pain and
happiness and with Elliot it's the same
the Big Challenge was getting the
emotion out of Elliott the connection
between the dragon and Pete is such a
big part of the film unlike Caesar
however Elliot wasn't portrayed by an
actor in a motion capture suit sand and
recalled we had a green wire mesh head
that I would lift over my head I tried
to move the head as best I thought it
would work for the shot and then we
track the head with our CG Elliot
Peter Jackson's King Kong won three
Academy Awards in 2006. one of which was
for wedded digital's groundbreaking pfx
work and the famous ape still looks
incredible today but the company became
even better at rendering furry animals
in the decade that followed in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
why does Eric Sanden said King Kong had
about 1 million hairs on him and
probably one quarter of those hairs were
simulated and we interpolated the rest
on Elliott we had 20 million and we
individually simulated each hair so when
Pete is petting or interacting with him
we get the interaction with the hair
according to weta's head of creatures
getting Elliot's fur to look real during
close-up interactions was definitely
tricky but The Airborne sequences proved
most challenging GEOS Johnson told
cartoon Brew there are lots of flying
shots in the movie and dialing in the
right amount of wind for a dragonflying
at very fast speeds also took some doing
fans reacted with a mixture of
bemusement and horror when the first
trailer for Disney's live-action Aladdin
drop revealing Will Smith's genie in all
his blueness for the first time
certainly the former Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air star knew he had some extremely
big shoes to fill but so did the visual
effects artist tasked with turning him
into a Disney icon the remakes VFX
supervisor Chaz Jarrett told CBR we
always sort of knew it was going to be
contentious I suppose that there would
be comparisons between our Genie and the
original But ultimately we felt
competent in the character we created
finalizing the Genie's look wasn't easy
either the team had been working on the
character for a year and a half by the
time the first trailer came out
constantly tinkering with his appearance
according to Jarrett he wasn't initially
supposed to look much like Smith at all
and the VFX team experimented with a
range of more cartoonish blue Genies
during pre-production ultimately however
they decided that they wouldn't be
making the best use of the film's
biggest star with this approach as Jared
says when you've got Will Smith you
realize what makes Will Smith work as
all the little Will Smith mannerisms if
you try putting those mannerisms on
something that isn't Will Smith it isn't
quite satisfied
according to Aladdin's visual effects
supervisor the iconic A Whole New World
scene would have played out quite
differently had it not been for director
guy Ritchie's Vision which asked Jarrett
and his team first started working on
the Magic Carpet Ride they envisioned
the journey taking place over the course
of an entire day but the titular Street
rat picking up the princess at Sunrise
and dropping her back off at the palace
right after Sunset Jared told Art of bfx
it worked well but guy felt strongly
that he wanted it all to happen at night
as in the original so he took helicopter
units to a number of locations to Jordan
and Namibia and Africa and filmed
elements the footage they captured
Blended well with the footage of mina
Masood and Naomi Scott who mind their
own recording of the song in front of a
giant blue screen it literally felt like
you know a Magic Carpet it was it was
incredible according to Naomi Scott the
scene was quite the workout too since
the actors had to support their own
weight as the rig shifted from side to
side
the dress transformation scene isn't
just one of the most iconic moments of
the original animated Cinderella and
it's one of the most iconic Disney
moments period naturally the studio used
Snippets from the scene to promote its
live action remake but this move ended
up backfiring big time in one trailer
for 2015 Cinderella star Lily James
appears to look a lot thinner around the
waist than she normally does and the
pre-bfx footage seemed to back up claims
that her waistline had been digitally
altered the British actress denied that
this was the case during an interview
with the Los Angeles Times insisting
that she was just a really healthy
person with a naturally small waist the
actress went on to complain about people
who were in her opinion kicking up a big
bus over nothing she said I think all
that stuff's so negative and you've got
to let it wash over your head but how
does she explain images that seem to
prove that her waist miraculously
changed sizes it's all down to her onset
Fairy Godmother costume designer Sandy
Powell James explained the skirts big
and the corset pulls me in and that's
the point that's the shape Sandy Powell
created
Tim Burton's remake of 1941's Dumbo was
one of the most ambitious Disney Live
Action projects from a visual effects
standpoint largely because of the
eponymous elephant Dumbo was animated
entirely from scratch in certain scenes
but when the blue eyed elephant needed
to interact with one of the humans in
the story creature Actor Ed Osmond came
in Osman was kitted out with crutch-like
arm extensions and had to walk around on
all fours for two to three hours per day
wearing a variety of different green
suits the actor told Insider it's a very
strange job the struggle with the arm
extensions is if you don't get the
Rhythm right if you don't do right arm
left leg left arm right leg you end up
walking like a table Osman was also
hooked up to an earpiece so he could
communicate with the film's VFX
supervisor NPC's Richard stammers during
his scenes according to stammers the 4
foot 6 actor was crucial to facilitating
physical interaction and eye lines
during some of the remake's most pivotal
moments stammers told Art of bfx having
Ed there allowed Tim to direct the
performance and we would always do our
first rehearsal and takes with that in
place
the hardest part of remaking Dumbo was
always going to be the flying scenes
it's easy to suspend your sense of
disbelief for animated movies but when
you're watching a live action film and
the animals look real that becomes a lot
harder to do in order to make the flight
scenes feel as genuine as possible the
VFX team did a lot of research into
birds and how their wings work in
relation to their body NPC's animation
supervisor Catherine Mullen told
animation World Network you're trying to
get as much anticipation and effort into
each of the two or three giant flaps
when Dumbo gets off the ground those
were the key moments also making sure
that he isn't rising up too quickly or
easily Dumbo flying solo was a challenge
but things got even more complicated
when the elephant had Riders a six-axis
rig was constructed and the VFX team
used what MPC supervisor Richard
stammers described as visual production
techniques in a nutshell director Tim
Burton could see a crude version of what
Dumbo would actually look like in the
finished scene there and then stammers
explains Ava Green and the children Nico
Parker and Finley hobbins got to ride
this rig with each wide or Midtown not
specially programmed onset compositing
enabled Tim to approve performances in
context to the animation within minutes
of each take being captured Winnie the
Pooh and the rest of the Hundred Acre
Wood gang were painstakingly brought to
life in 2018's live-action Christopher
Robin but bringing the honey-loving bear
and his friends out of the woods and
into England's capital city was a
mammoth task for the visual effects crew
crane store's VFX supervisor Chris
Lawrence singled out some key members of
his team during an in-depth interview
with shoot online including the vendor's
Global director of animation Michael
Ames Lawrence explained Ames brought an
incredible attention to detail and the
valuable knowledge of a practitioner
often he would simply sketch exactly
what he wanted I thought with Winnie the
Pooh he achieved one of the most subtle
nuanced animated screen performances
ever seen no this is very confusing it
may be the hunger you've just eaten oh
that's right
maybe I didn't need enough bringing
Winnie the Pooh to the real world meant
that actor Ewan McGregor had to act
opposite some pretty creepy headless
dolls in some scenes but this was
nothing new for the Scottish star who
told Screen Rant I did it all in the
Star Wars movies quite a lot it's like a
sort of skill just something else that
you have to learn to do
there are a lot of weird and wonderful
characters in Alice in Wonderland and
bringing each one to life in live action
posed a unique challenge for the remakes
crew animation supervisor David schild
told Cinema Blend from a technical
perspective stain was incredibly tricky
since every shot required an animated CG
body underneath a photographic element
of Crispin Glover's head because the
knave of Hearts is so tall Glover spent
the entirety of the shoot on stilts this
guaranteed that eye lines would match up
and make things a whole lot easier for
the VFX team but for Glover it didn't
come easy according to shelb the actor
spent several days hobbling around the
set trying to get the hang of it but at
least the process of getting ready to
shoot wasn't too complicated as Glover
himself says there were no Prosthetics
there was nothing like that although
there was a scar application the rest of
it was done in green screen
Tim Burton didn't return to direct the
sequel to Alice in Wonderland but Disney
did manage to secure the services of Ken
Ralston who helped oversee the visual
effects on the first movie knowing full
well that Alice Through the Looking
Glass was going to be an even bigger
challenge for the visual effects
Department Ralston brought his Sony
Pictures imageworks colleague Jay rad
along for some much needed support red
told animation World Network when we
started looking at the show we knew it
was going to be gigantic there was more
variety in this one than the first one
you could safely say it was bigger there
were more buried environments than in
the first film star miyabashikovska
worked with a lot of green screen in the
first movie so she was well used to it
by the time the sequel began shooting
the major difference the second time
around was that her role was a lot more
physical with more running and jumping
in ball the actor told quirky inspired
sustaining that level of energy when you
have quite little coming back at you in
terms of the sets is challenging it's
just a big green blob of light and
there's not much we had a few more sets
on this film which was really great but
otherwise it's quite like an abstract
experience
when Angelina Jolie accepted the lead
role in Disney's Maleficent she brought
in her own personal makeup artist and a
special effects makeup Guru together
they created the anti-heroine's look
staying as close to the animated version
from 1959 Sleeping Beauty as possible
the crafted facial Prosthetics to give
Jolie those high cheekbones which
reportedly made execs at The Mouse House
rather nervous Ariane Titan the makeup
artist who created said facial
Prosthetics told fashionista they were
like wait what Prosthetics on Angelina
why are we covering Iraq they were not
very keen on it Jolie insisted on
keeping them and ultimately got her way
but the movie still utilized plenty of
visual effects after all this is a
fantasy movie featuring some major
action sequences the kind of scenes that
can only be achieved with CGI according
to Kelly Port the movie's VFX supervisor
he and his team decided to adopt a less
is more approach which paid off
handsomely he says for me visual effects
are a tool and should always be thought
of as a tool to support the film they
always need to serve the purpose of the
film and move the story along that's
when there are most successful with
Maleficent we knew what was working well
and what to pay attention to
according to NPC's Jessica Norman Disney
wanted the latest in visual effects for
2019's Maleficent Mistress of evil there
were over a thousand bfx artists working
on the big budget sequel at one stage
many of them pouring their time and
energy into Angelina Jolie's flying
sequences Norman told Art of bfx the
actress and the other fake characters
were filmed whilst attached to operated
tuning fork rigs on a blue screen stage
in some shots we attached CG Wings some
shots are full or partial CG takeovers
in a behind the scenes feature at Jolie
revealed what it's like being strapped
into a rotating toony Fork rig for hours
on end they're doing the up and the down
and the spin but your body is dictating
whether you're turning left or right and
then they have to go with you Jolie
later told Hello magazine that she and
co-star Sam Riley even had a near Miss
while filming a flying sequence
thankfully though they both made it out
in one piece
foreign